a un proceso político por presunta
corrupción se vería abocado el
presidente ecuatoriano Guillermo lasso
tras una recomendación de la comisión
legislativa que investigaba el caso
conocido como gran padrino la comisión
de la verdad justicia y lucha contra la
corrupción con seis votos afirmativos
aprobó el informe por el cual se
evidenciaría el presunto comedimiento de
delitos tipificados en el código
orgánico integral penal a través del
supuesto entramado de corrupción en
empresas públicas la comisión se empezó
a acusar al lazo de traición a la patria
pero cambió las acusaciones por delitos
contra la seguridad del estado y
corrupción el gobierno lo calificó de
ataque a la razón en entrevista para
France 24 Wendy Reyes analista política
dice que la coyuntura que se crea tras
esta decisión no es favorable para el
gobierno en este momento es que estamos
en una crisis en una crisis
gubernamental acabamos de tener unas
elecciones locales en donde también
había un referéndum por parte del
ejecutivo que la estaba promoviendo y
perdió el referendo Brasil salieron
todas las preguntas que él impartía con
el no también ha perdido mucha fuerza
política a nivel local casi no tiene
fuerza a nivel de la asamblea nacional
Entonces nos encontramos con una crisis
que además existen ya de parte del
movimiento indígena No es cierto también
anuncios de que van a haber nuevas
movilizaciones tuvimos ya dos paros
fuertes la recomendación del juicio no
es vinculante Por ende para que se lleve
a cabo la mayoría de los 137 miembros de
la asamblea debe aprobar la
recomendación de la comisión y los
legisladores deben presentar una
petición formal al presidente de la
asamblea la recomendación será discutida
el próximo cuatro de marzo en el pleno
del legislativo en 2022 algunos
legisladores intentaron destituir a lazo
durante las protestas de organizaciones
indígenas un juicio político en su
momento fallido pero que ahora se vuelve
a cernir sobre la figura del presidente